[Music]
in
facebook to the rescue news
yay facebook the company that i stream
for follow me on my stream
put it below please ryan thank you
submitted by
rush hour
fly lights it's fly lights you click
nishishi i've never seen it what what
it's a cult classic i know i really need
to i'm sorry okay all right why didn't
you tell me it's bomb i said
boom yeah it's just like
an emergency facebook post and a global
network of friends saved two american
travelers lives in boston
bali
like i have to be the one with the
information i think you got the l
for that one i got molded
remember that one
stop it just stop talking get out of
this room
is it like demoted i don't know where it
comes from
okay i'm sorry i really don't know where
it comes from oh you got moded how do
you not know that
yeah like demoted like you got corrected
so hard yeah motorboating but you got
corrected so hard that you have no other
words to say what do the kids see they
kids think these days they
get embodied you get well you got
wrecked
yeah you got anal probe body is my
favorite
bodied yeah that's an east coast thing
you got bodied
like you got pretty much killed oh you
got sleep with the fishes
wait how old is everyone don't ask me
okay 33.
let's say i have a nephew that's older
than you holy [ __ ] really yeah wow
all right so this story here it's about
michael and stacy they were driving the
scooter
in bali right a van passed them as they
were going up a hill
their brakes didn't work for some reason
and then they made the turn
too high like high speed high speed and
so they ended up
falling off like the hill like a sort of
hill
and so they ended up slipping down
michael his local and
the sim card cell phone it flew out of
like i don't know somewhere
he flew away but then he he realized he
did have his american cell phone on him
thankfully because then he was able to
take it out of his jacket
and he put out an sos on facebook
so this is michael and stacy there they
met while they were traveling
um she currently lives in south korea
oh look at them cool all international
and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
like they travel a lot and so they
decided to meet up in bali and they were
trying to go somewhere else that's dope
and then this is the sos that michael
sent he's like help
in danger call police oh damn and then
he has been making friends from all over
the world
from all these trips that he's been
doing and so thankfully there was
multiple people trying to help and like
come up with
phone numbers a lot of these people
thought that he might have gotten hacked
so luckily his friend amy
she saw that status in about a minute or
two after it went up
so then she went on facebook and she
pressed the call button because you know
how facebook
oh no yeah and so she was able to speak
to him
and he was disoriented he didn't know
where he was but
he was able to drop a location pin
coca-cola
yeah so then this is an iphone for sure
androids don't do that oh it's whatsapp
well they could they
this is what's that but they said
facebook i don't know oh because he
posted the status but he messaged on
yeah okay and then like she said that he
called it
all right so yeah here's the pin and
then he's like woods by a river
can't move and she's like okay i can see
that on the map he's like help
she's like try and stay as calm as you
can we are working to get you help and
he's like girl with me
okay and then she says is the girl okay
can she get up and
go to the road to get help he's like no
because the girl
was also very badly injured damn
um it's a miracle they're alive yeah
yeah yeah there was a friend from la
that used
maps to figure out exactly like where he
was and like
yeah like trying to track everything so
who called the bali police
and then a friend in prague posted
numbers to the consulate
uh of a friend and another and then so a
friend
in the netherlands is so cool to have
friends
and then the friend in bangkok called
the friend in [ __ ] brussels
no so the friend in netherlands called
the police in bali
and then they were able to get him help
and then they called liam neeson's and
he went to go rescue them
i mean you could you have fans and you
have so many stalkers that like they
if you needed their help if you needed
their help
they could triangulate everything your
soccer has probably
watched you fall off the scooter yeah
he'll probably like find me take my
underwear and then just leave
you'll be like oh no gina it's you and
then they'll pull out your underwear and
run away and while they're [ __ ] smart
and then you're like ah help me
he's like oh [ __ ] i'm sorry i got the
bra
yeah so michael he had surgery on his
skull to fix a fracture then on his
wrist
which was broken and then in his abdomen
to fix the
perforation and then he also had chest
tubes inserted to inflate his lungs
oh god they got [ __ ] totally stacey
wasn't that bad
she suffered a fracture both her
cheekbones as well as her nose and her
left
wrist and she also split her tongue
that sounds kind of bad too it was but
not as bad as him because she was able
to go home he has to be that's funny how
she's like no she can't get up
but he's the one that was [ __ ] up oh
wow
oh man that's road rash on her leg
probably
and then there's them at the free nose
job dope
while they look [ __ ] up yeah yeah fun
free nose job that's what i'm saying my
girlfriend she like doesn't like her
nose she's like god i wish i could just
like get into a fight and they just hit
my nose so i could just go get a nose
job
that's why i drive so close to the
steering wheel i'm waiting for the air
bag to deploy
why you want a nose job no i want like a
bridge i want like a bridge i want it to
look like this
too much of a bridge you can castle i
want that just get injections
my fiance is not a huge fan of like
touching the face because he thinks once
you touch one thing on the face
everyone's gonna assume everything's
been touched
so i have to like have like a real
medical reason you know
so i'm just waiting like this every time
i drive aren't you scared though that
your kid's not gonna look like you
you think i'm gonna [ __ ] with their
problem i'm just trying to live my best
friend i start doing whatever i'm gonna
kid this is my best life your kids don't
look like you no more
maybe look i'll do you a solid when we
leave today i'll ram into your car real
quick
yeah see that's how friends are for edit
this out no proof
yes we don't need proof
yeah but it's pretty cool they had
friends all over the world trying to
help them that's why when people go
i want to travel and then like just
unplug and leave my cell phone
and i'm like why would you do such a
thing yeah you turn into mom
yeah i'm like why what that's so
irresponsible with his hands that's on
his waist
i mean yeah cause you could just hold on
to it you don't have to look at the
phone so you're telling me you can't
control yourself that you always got to
be [ __ ] doing this [ __ ]
just leave it in your pocket just in
case because of the gps yeah
has it ever happened to you when you
just pull out your phone you're on it
you don't even realize when you did that
you're like oh [ __ ] all the time [ __ ]
i'm on my phone again i know i'm having
a blast when i'm not looking at my phone
yeah
true but i do uh wish that
i had service at certain places because
i take pictures and i'm like this is
awesome and you want to upload it at
that moment
oh for that reason yeah but then when
you're like hiking in the middle of the
[ __ ] forest and
there's no service you're like well i
don't know how they triangulated that
[ __ ] and got that to work
because
i would have been dead yeah every time i
hear people like i'm gonna go be one
with nature and just get off the grid
i'm like have fun dying [ __ ] no one's
gonna find you
at least when i die you can find me
probably in my bedroom somewhere
i'll go off the grid but i always tell
people mm-hmm
do you like going into the wild me yeah
no
i hate i hate i hate the wild i hate it
so much
i don't know i feel like in la we just
pay so much for rent and for houses like
why do i have to go
and pay to like rent a spot in malibu to
like camp yeah it's just me because it's
not even the wild
i know right she's like the hell that's
the wild
but wait
i'll save you to her credit though she
like
you just moved here or something right
yeah yeah so she doesn't know the area
where's your
where did you move from atlanta georgia
anyone that you have to pay for is not
really the wild
oh really yeah because that means
there's an organization there that's
accepting payment with the
eye okay you drive up to your spot and
that's where you can
no i have like high levels of paranoia
i'm out of this world well obviously
like you're
small and you're like this little a
little girl like if you [ __ ]
of course like right now you don't have
a macbook like
whether i do what are you talking about
it's covered what
there's a slide one but i have to slide
one but won't you feel
safer in the forest where there's no
humans no because look at that beaver
guy
what if you had what if
would it do it what if what if your
fiance had a gun
no no no no no i feel like your fiance's
so beautiful to even have a gun
i feel like he would just really try to
reason with the person trying to kill us
like he'd be like sit down tell me about
your life yeah tell me why you want to
kill us
i feel like he would wear a suit to go
camping you want to kill him
no he acts like he likes it though he
acts like he's like a wilderness man
because he watches that wilderness
channel where he gets stung by ants so
he thinks he's like a part of it
and then we'll like go anywhere with
like a tree and he's like oh let's go
it's hot out here
i feel i only i only imagine your fiance
in a permanent suit because that's how i
met him
yeah like if you were to go camping he
would just have like a camouflage suit
yeah that's dope you kind of want one of
those
right his swimsuit is like you're his
wetsuit's a [ __ ] tuxedo you know like
he's just always in a suit
does he own shorts like
dressy shorts like those striped white
boy trousers
like slack shorts yeah it reminds me of
like uh if he would wear that he will
wear it with boat shoes yes exactly yeah
right okay that's his style though i
know the kind of guy he is does he have
any white tube socks
tube socks no they're just dress socks
right just dress socks all navy
feels like a navy thing yeah see fiancee
i know you
yeah i mean he is in the diamond
industry
yeah yeah he fits that world
i don't know i i feel like nature is one
of those things where i
need it now like i [ __ ] fiend for it
like it was crack
and i just need to be in it and like
feel
[ __ ] i don't know i never win
i never make myself go but then i feel
like i never make myself go but when i'm
there i really appreciate it like oh my
god i'm so glad i came back
it's like a reset button yeah yeah it is
especially if i could wear the least
amount of clothes possible
[ __ ] jungle it feels good i'm just
thinking of
all the bugs tattoo like everywhere you
know how stupid i am
when i get bit by mosquitoes i feel like
nature
found a way to pull out certain parts of
my body
to re-correct myself because that shit's
acupuncture by nature
mosquito puncture yeah that's how that's
how mother nature connected with you
yeah i'm just thinking like well nature
was just re-correcting my body with
mosquitoes
[Music]
[Music]
hmm